hey guys a what's up I'm Alana and
welcome to my channel it is a new year
and with that I think there are a lot of
people who are finally hoping to get fit
or lose some weight or get healthy in
2017 and I thought that I would finally
share the story of how I lost 40 pounds
or around 20 kilos I had been trying to
lose weight for literally years and I
would go to the gym and I would try to
eat healthy and then I would just give
up the biggest problem that I had was
that I pretty much can't do cardio I
have really bad asthma so every time I
would try to brought on a treadmill I
would just get asked more after a few
minutes and give up I also have ankle
problems which gives me ankle pain foot
pain knee pain back pain just every
combination of things in the world that
made me hate doing cardio and I didn't
realize that you could lose weight and
stay fit without really needing to do
cardio turns out you can and I guess for
the newcomers who don't know me very
well maybe I'll put a picture of my
stomach on the thumbnail or something or
I could I'm gonna show you guys this is
gonna be real weird but I'm just gonna
show you my stomach so that you don't
think I'm just some skinny [ __ ] with no
muscle talking about stuff on YouTube
that is how my stomach currently looks
that was weird so you know I complained
about not being able to lose weight and
I kept giving up on going to the gym and
then I found Lila Pradas 12-week lean
body program this is not sponsored in
any way there is no [ __ ] way that I
could get a bodybuilding website to
sponsor my youtube channel no I
literally gave the day followed this
guide I will leave a link to it in my
description I don't follow it anymore
I've just taken that and kind of adapted
it to what I do now but basically I
focus on certain muscle groups every day
I will have a biceps and triceps day
where I try and do three separate
exercises that use my biceps will
usually do eight to ten reps and three
sets so that means I do eight bicep
curls in a row my break is usually a
couple of minutes but I mostly just time
it on when I stop puffing quite as much
I do them to failure which means that by
the eighth rep I should not be able to
lift my arm again to do the ninth the
overall point of that is that as soon as
I can consistently lift to eight all
three sets the
time that I do my bicep walk out I'm
going to increase the weight that I'm
lifting so say day one is biceps and
triceps the next day will be shoulders
and back the next day it will be thighs
and glutes
I don't strictly stick to those days
because sometimes one muscle is more so
than the other so I just swap things in
and out generally based on the muscles
that I really want to focus on or the
strength that I want to grow now I do
have to mention to especially women who
are watching this video doing weights is
not going to make you muscle e or manly
I've been lifting weights for nearly
three years
I still have boobs I still have really
big hips getting really muscly or manly
looking requires a lot more than just
lifting weights it requires a hell of a
lot of carbs and protein and it is
really hard for women to do so I would
say if you're new to working out and
this is something that you want to start
doing go into it with the mindset that
you will lift as heavy as you can and if
you feel like you're not liking the way
that you look then dial that don't think
oh I should do this wider because I
don't want to look manly because it's
probably not going to happen and it'll
just set you back so if a weight loss
specifically of course diet is a huge
huge huge thing that is probably the
most important thing in getting visible
abs and it's also going to make you feel
a hell of a lot healthier and for me
especially more energetic
I mean finding healthy things to eat
during the day you really just need to
google it there are so many resources
online to help you figure out how to eat
healthy and it is actually a lot cheaper
than most people make it out to be you
buying your food every Sunday and
cooking it every Sunday will save you a
lot of money in the long run when I
first started losing weight
I cut out pretty much all bread I tried
not to eat any pasta and I also cut out
all soft drinks or sodas like coke I
don't do that anymore but I think that
was a good way to start out and of
course this is just the stuff that work
for me I know that some people are going
to classes works a lot better of course
cardio is good for you I recommend doing
cardio I still do it
a couple of times a month it took me I
think about seven months to lose the 40
pounds / 20 kilos that I lost and since
then I have gained some weight and lost
some weight again and it's always been
this constant cycle everyone changes and
fluctuates all the time it's totally
normal don't feel bad about it let
yourself eat things with your family on
Christmas like food is not your enemy
like I said before look at food as the
way that it can power you because that
is also a huge thing if you don't eat
enough you might gain muscle you need
food to fuel your body and on that same
night don't feel bad if you mister gym
sometimes and maybe start out with three
days a week or two days a week and then
build yourself up just don't let
yourself get scared because that
definitely happened to me when I started
out I was like wow my body's really so
or wow I can't run as much as this
person oh wow
in some cases that I was the biggest
person in the gym the only way you can
change that is if you keep going if
anyone has any more questions or you
feel like there's something that I
didn't cover here please let me know
more than happy to help out alrighty
everyone that is it for me thank you
guys so much and like I said I will
leave the link to that website with the
full plan that I used just keep it
bookmarked and use it every day that's
exactly what I get I will see y'all next
time